Welcome to the third
lecture of 3091.
Let's get started.
Today is a very
exciting day, because we
are going to discover
the electron together.
That's our goal today.
It's right there,
discovery of the electron.
And we're going to start talking
about models of the atom.
Before we do that,
I want to count.
I want to count, because
that's what we did on Friday.
And we'll use this problem
actually twice today.
Either way, like if I
do a problem in class,
and it's in a goody bag
and stuff, I don't know,
it might be the kind of thing
you might be asked on a quiz.
I'm just saying.
So that's good to know.
If I ask you this question,
because we counted on Friday,
we learned how to count.
And we learned about the
mole and Avogadro's number
and how that gets us into and
out of the atomic world, right?
So if I say, how
many gallium atoms
are this strip of gallium?
Well, we can do that now, right?
Because well, how do you start?
This is where you start.
And you are all taking it
with you everywhere now.
Remember on Friday,
we talked about how
you got to bring it with you
everywhere and tweet about it
and send me pictures
and all that.
I need the density, right?
I need the density.
Density in the periodic table.
Let's start with the density.
So if I have the
density of gallium
and I looked that up as 5.9
grams per centimeter cubed.
OK, that's good.
Well, you know, from the
strip I can measure it
with the super most
accurate ruler in the world
that you have now in your
hands from the goody bag.
And you see those
are the measurements.
And so if you measure
it, you have a volume.
OK, it's those three
numbers multiplied.
I won't write it out.
It's 0.5 centimeters cubed.
And so now with the
density and the volume,
I get that that
strip has 2.95 grams.
OK?
Now that sounds pretty good.
It's promising, but I want
the number of atoms, right?
I want the number of atoms.
And that's where, again, you
go to here, because in there
is the grams per mole and also
the atomic mass units, which,
as we talked about Friday,
are the same thing.
Right?
And so if I look that up,
I have that for gallium,
we have 69.723 grams
per mole, right?
And so that means
that in 2.95 grams,
I have 2.95 divided by
that number, 69.723--
let's raise this up a little--
which equals 0.0423 moles.
I still have not answered the
question because the question
says, how many atoms?
Right?
But that's where n sub a, or
the mole, or this dozen, right?
But it's not a dozen.
It's a much bigger number.
But this number, Avogadro's
number, comes in.
And so in that
strip of gallium--
ah!
No.
In that strip of gallium,
you've got, in the GA strip,
you've got 0.0423
times na atoms.
That's something like, you know,
2.5 times 10 to the 22nd atoms.
That's a lot of atoms in that
strip, but I was able to do.
But the secret is the--
right, remember?
One atomic mass unit
gets you back and forth
between one gram per mole.
And by the way, the atomic
mass unit is nothing.
It's just a mass unit.
I mean, one AMU happens
to be, by the way,
oh, roughly 1.66 times 10
to the minus 27th kilograms.
Huh!
That works because now you can
multiply this by a whole mole,
and it's a gram.
Back and forth, OK?
Good counting.
Starting with counting.
We're going to
end with counting.
But in between, we're going to
discover something beautiful,
because last week--
OK, the thesis of
this whole class,
remember, is
electronic structure
holds the key to everything.
Everything in your
life can be understood
if you understood the electronic
structure of the elements.
Week one, last week,
we talked about this.
We built it on Friday.
We talked about elements.
We did a few reactions.
We talked about balancing.
We made sure we
have enough nitrogen
to grow plants for 100 million
more years, eliminate reagents.
This week, we're going
to answer the question,
why are these things different?
We're switching gears, right?
We know that there are
these indivisible atoms now.
And we built a whole
table of them, right?
Mendeleev.
But now we want to
know why they're
different from one another.
What causes that difference?
And that starts with the
discovery of the electron.
And really this is such--
so let's write this here.
We'll have this board.
This is such a great story.
This is a detective story that
starts with an atom looking--
so these are atom models, OK?
So back in, oh, let's say, 18--
ah, OK, 460.
If it's Democritus,
it's 460 B.C.
And then remember, we sort of
went all the way to Dalton,
who, in 1803, he
said, yup, Democritus,
we're going with that.
We're going with that.
And oh, there are
these indivisible
things called atoms.
So that was 1803.
But we need to understand
them in order to explain this.
We need to understand them.
And so this is a
detective story.
It's one of the greatest
ones ever, ever, ever
played out in science.
It led to nothing less than the
understanding of all of nature.
OK, now, how did it start?
Well, it started
with J.J. Thomson.
Now, so J.J. Thomson--
by the way, he won the Nobel
Prize for this discovery.
He's credited with
discovering the electron.
Also seven of his students
won the Nobel Prize.
That's cool!
And I remind my graduate
students of that
all the time, without trying
to put any pressure on them.
How did he do it?
Well, you see, he
had these things.
There is his lab.
There's Thomson,
there's his lab.
And these things were around.
They're called
cathode ray tubes.
Cathode ray tubes.
What do they do?
All right?
Well, your grandparents would
know something about them.
I'll talk about that
in a few minutes.
But Thomson, Thomson
was interested in seeing
what he saw on this thing here.
And that's the
photographic plate.
So what we're going
to do is we're just
going to draw the
cathode ray tube,
draw it as best I can here.
So there is a cathode ray
tube, and over here we've
got a cathode, and over
here we've got an anode.
So this would be a cathode,
and this here is an anode.
OK, good.
Now, that means that if I hook
the other two pieces of metal,
two pieces of metal,
and if I hook them up
to a voltage supply, then
I can get charge on them.
We know that already.
But what they didn't understand
is what happened next.
You see, because if you crank
the voltage up really high
and you put a
phosphor screen here--
so this was a phosphor screen--
and if you crank the
voltage up high enough,
and this is what Thomson did,
you pump the gas out of it.
Right?
So you get it so there's
not too much stuff in there.
Then what happens is
something shot across
and lit up the screen.
Something.
What?
They really didn't know,
and when you don't know,
you experiment and you
apply the scientific method.
And one of the things
that Thomson did
is he said, well, what if I
put some charge plates here,
like this and this?
So I have a [? set, ?] right?
So it is said, this is going
to have charge that flies off.
We know that, because we
kind of know what happens.
But he didn't know
what was happening.
He's just cranking the voltage
up, and all of a sudden the
screen lights up.
So he's like, well, let me put
some charge plates here and see
what happens.
And what happened there is
it went like this, right?
And it struck the
phosphor screen there,
and it glowed there.
So that's with charge,
with charge plates.
Right?
No charge plates, just
to be perfectly clear.
And he could play
with this, right?
And people do play with
this, to my great surprise,
if you go onto the internet
and you Google this.
You find people make
these and play with them,
and that's a magnet.
This is what it
looks like, right?
But we didn't know
what this was, right?
So that's a magnet,
and this person
is just turning over whether
which part of the magnet, where
the magnetic field is oriented.
And you can see, you can
really mess with this.
What could it be?
It's responding to
an external field.
It's responding to an external
field, so we know right away,
this tells us that atoms are
not the ultimate form of matter.
Atoms were not the
ultimate form of matter.
That was a big deal, because
the atoms here were neutral.
They didn't respond, so this
must be something else that's
flying off and responding,
that I can see visually
on this photographic plate.
It must be something else.
Well, he was also--
Thomson was-- oh, ha!
Going down here, I'm
going to use this
so it's right next to it.
He was not able to measure
the mass of these things,
but he was able,
using a combination
of magnetic and electric fields
and the little bit of Maxwell,
some ENM, he was able to deduce
the charge to mass ratio.
So this falls over here.
I'll put it here, from Thomson.
So he was able to get
the charge to mass ratio.
And he was able to measure
that at minus 1.76 times 10
to the 11th coulombs
per kilogram.
Now, he knew it was negatively
charged because of this, right?
He put the plates
on, and it wanted
to avoid the negative plate.
So they knew their
ENM at the time.
They knew that the negative
charges would repel.
So he knew that it
was a negative charge.
Now, the last thing, oh, is this
one important for chemistry!
He would swap in different
materials, different metals
for the cathode and anode.
For the cathode especially.
And the results were the same.
The results were the same.
Oh!
Independent,
independent of metal.
Independent of the metal.
That meant this
thing that he was
observing for the first
time was fundamental.
There's something
fundamental about it.
Fundamental!
This was a really big deal.
And it really opened up
the idea that the atom
had something else in it.
Now, see, Thomson knew that the
atom was neutral, like I said.
So you've got these
charged things
coming off of these
atoms, which are neutral.
That means that it must consist
of these charged particles.
But if it's neutral, it's
got to have the other charge
of particle in it as well.
And so the detective
story goes on.
So this would be
Thomson around 18--
oh, things really picked up.
1807.
And he said, well,
OK, these electrons
must be inside of the atom.
That's how I'm liberating them.
Crank up the voltage, and
they must be in there.
But so must positive charges.
So must positive charges, OK?
And that was Thomson's model.
So at that time,
you could really
have this picture of
stuff inside the atom.
Now, like I said, he
couldn't measure--
they didn't have a
scale good enough
to measure the mass
of the electron.
He could get it out, all right?
But it was Millikan and
his very famous experiments
called the oil drop experiments
that gave us the actual charge.
And then from this
ratio, we can get
the mass of this
mystery thing that
was coming out of atoms, OK?
And instead of trying to
draw the Millikan experiment,
I found a wonderful, short,
like one-ish minute video,
which I'll play,
because it shows how
the Millikan experiment worked.
It's really cool.
Oh!
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Robert Millikan, working
at the University of Chicago,
succeeded in measuring the
charge on the electron.
That's not happening.
- He allowed the fine spray of
oil to settle through a hole,
into a chamber where he
could observe their fall.
The top and bottom
of the chamber
consisted of electrically
charged plates.
He introduced a
source of x-rays which
can cause creation of charges
when they strike matter.
Charges reduced by the x-rays
attached to an oil droplet,
and producing one or more
charges on the droplet.
When there is no voltage of
light, the fall of the droplets
is determined by the mass
and the viscosity of air
through which they fall.
When a voltage is
applied, the droplets
that have a negative charge
will fall more slowly,
stop falling, or even rise,
depending on the number
of charges on them.
By adjusting the applied voltage
and observing the droplets,
both with voltage
off and voltage
on, Millikan was
able to determine
that the charges on
the droplets were
all multiples on a
smallest value, 1.6 times
10 to the minus 19th Coulombs.
He took this to be the
charge on a single electron.
[END PLAYBACK]
All right, so now you see
that that would have been--
I hope that was--
could you hear that in the back?
Sort of, OK.
All right.
Oh, I got this.
You know, that
would have been hard
for me to draw the
animation, but what
a brilliant experiment, right?
So spray some oil
in a container, OK?
Try to get the drop small.
You don't know how small
they're going to be.
And then as they fall--
OK, have an electric
field inside there.
And then as they fall, zip
them, zap them to charge them.
You also don't know
how much charge
you're putting on them, right?
But you're charging them.
And if they're charged
and they're in a field,
and there are these tiny, little
microscopic droplets of oil,
they're going to maybe slow
down or suspend or maybe even go
the other way.
And what he observed by doing
this over and over again,
that there was some multiple
that you never got below,
right?
And you couldn't say
necessarily for 100% certainty
that it was the fundamental
charge of electrons.
It might have been
a multiple of that.
But it was pretty clear.
You could never get below that.
So that was the charge discovery
in this detective story,
and it allowed us to understand
that the electron had a mass
and it had a charge.
And that we knew both
of them at the time.
So at the time then, we
already had a much deeper
understanding, if
you think about it,
just four years later than
the time of Dalton because
of these two experiments.
Yeah?
So we said that Thomson was
56-- he'd be [INAUDIBLE] 1940s,
so wouldn't that be 1907?
1856 to huh?
Thomson was alive.
Alive.
[INAUDIBLE]
I think I read in my--
he was ahead of his time.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you very much.
I think I read this
wrong, and that's
because I don't
have my glasses on.
So now that I look
at that, it wasn't
that small of a distance.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you very much.
You make mistakes.
You make mistakes, and
that is how you learn!
[LAUGHTER]
You don't make progress.
Progress has almost
nothing to do with success.
I mean this.
I'm using my own mistake
here as an example.
Progress has almost
nothing to do with success.
Progress has only
to do with what
you choose to do with failure.
Did somebody just say, whoa?
Thank you.
That hit me here.
All right.
OK, let's do a why this matters.
Let's do a why this matters.
Why does this matter?
Well, because, see,
these guys were
trying to figure out what
was inside of an atom.
But other people,
like John Baird,
said, well, wait a second.
You just gave me a paintbrush.
You gave me a paintbrush.
Look at this.
That's a paintbrush,
painting with a magnet.
It really is.
And the screen would
light up over here.
And so he said,
well, I can paint.
I can paint pictures.
And this really is the
first television screen.
This was the first TV
screen, and all they
needed to do, there--
OK, right?
There it is.
Look!
That's a cathode ray tube.
Maybe that's one of Thomson's
students who won a Nobel Prize.
And but now, you put
this down, and you put
these sort of things around it.
What are those things?
Magnetic fields,
that's all it is.
It's just magnetic fields.
It's Thomson's
experiments, right?
But now they're using it
to zip the beam around
faster than you're
[INAUDIBLE] keep up with so
that it looks like a picture.
Now, electron painting had
never been done before,
because we didn't know that
we had these electrons.
But as soon as we
knew, boy, did that
launch a completely
new era of screens.
Right?
The era of screens.
We don't use cathode ray tubes.
I was going to say,
ask your grandparents.
They'll tell you about
the cathode ray tube
TVs, which they all had.
But you know, we don't
use cathode ray tubes
to paint with electrons
today in that way,
but we still paint
with electrons today.
Right?
Youre OLED screen
is still simply
an electron-based
painting tool, right?
OK, we're just
pumping the electrons
into the phosphor
in a different way,
and we'll be talking
about that as we
go through the rest of
this week and we understand
how electrons
interact with light
coming in and out of an atom.
OK, so that's my
why this matters.
And by the way, a
side note here is
that when TVs first came
along, green was pretty easy.
There were a lot of chemistries
that were used for this screen.
You put a different
chemistry here,
and it lights up differently
when electrons hit it.
Why?
Wait until Wednesday.
Green was easy.
Yellow was easy.
Red was hard.
They couldn't get a good red.
And of course, that's
essentially the reason
there were no color TVs
until the '60s, right?
And the answer, of
course, was here.
The answer was that there
was a phosphor that worked,
but it was yttrium orthovanadate
with a little bit of europium
added to it.
Just a little bit of europium.
Why did that work?
Again, we need to understand how
electrons interact with matter,
which is where we're going.
And speaking of yttrium,
speaking of yttrium,
this is also a side story,
but it's kind of worth noting.
You know, elements are
named often-- well,
elements can be named
after many things, right?
In this case, it was named
after Ytterby, Sweden.
Ytterby, Sweden, is
a pretty cool place.
They had this one cave.
You got to go to it.
It's really cool, because four
elements of the periodic table
were all discovered
from Ytterby, Sweden,
in this one cave.
Four!
And I keep thinking, where
is that cave in Cambridge?
[LAUGHTER]
Hm?
They cannot discover
any more elements,
because there's no other way
to mess with the name Ytterby.
[LAUGHTER]
That's pretty cool.
That's a cool cave.
That's worth visiting.
All right, so the structure
of the atom in the 1900s--
thank you for the
date correction.
1900, the structure of the
atom was as follows, all right?
The atom is
electrically neutral,
but there are these
negative charges.
These negative charges
called electrons.
The electron has
a very small mass.
We know that from the oil
drop experiments, right?
Which means that
the bulk of the atom
is positive, because the bulk
of the mass of the atom--
you know, the atom
weighs one thing.
The electron is
just a small part
of that in terms of the mass,
so most of the mass is positive.
And there was a question.
OK?
So we're getting
somewhere, but how
do these charges really look?
How do these charges
arrange inside of this atom?
Is Thomson really right?
And that was the next part
of our detective story,
was to really understand
what these charges are
doing inside the atom.
I'm carrying this
around like my security
blanket, which is making me
feel very secure right now.
And you should all carry it too.
This part of the story relies
on another type of energy
that was being
discovered at the time.
And you all may recognize
this as radiation.
Now, radioactivity,
radioactivity
is nothing more
than ray activity.
This is what they named
it after, ray activity.
That's radioactivity.
And it was these three
people who really pioneered
the understanding-- gesundheit--
of radioactivity
and in particular,
the fact that some elements
seemed to just be radioactive.
What did that mean?
Well, it means they gave
off these rays of energy.
That means they gave off
these rays of energy.
You had Henri Becquerel.
You had Marie Curie
and Pierre Curie.
Notice I didn't even try.
Where's Jerome?
I didn't even try
with the French.
But anyway, they took these
materials, like uranium ore,
minerals made out of
uranium, and they said,
this stuff looks like it's got
something coming off of it.
Let's see if we can find what
elements are causing that.
All right?
And Marie Curie, she found
polonium and radium this way,
those two elements.
Polonium named after her home
country, her native country
of Poland.
And this stuff gave
off all this energy,
and it was so energetic they
could literally put it in a cup
and have some writing there and
put it in a super-dark room,
and it would
illuminate the picture.
Right?
It would illuminate the picture.
But this is not a recommended
way to light your pictures.
So Pierre carried a vial of
radium, because it was so cool
and it glowed!
He was like, look at this stuff!
Right?
And he actually did have
bouts of radiation poisoning,
although he died,
tragically, when
he was struck by a
horse-drawn carriage in 1906.
Marie lived much
longer and won two--
but also died because
of radiation poisoning.
But she won two Nobel prizes.
First woman to win a Nobel
Prize, only woman to win two,
and for only person
ever to win one
in two different disciplines,
physics and chemistry.
She was quite a
brilliant scientist.
And they gave us this radiation.
Now, OK, but see, OK, they
were really into radiation,
but it was Rutherford who
said, well, wait a second.
Maybe I can use this stuff to
keep going along this story.
Right?
Rutherford was like,
well, maybe there's
something we could do
with this radiation.
And so what happened?
Oh, there it is!
And so I'm going to put it
right above it so you can see.
So he said, well, OK, if I take
something that glows, maybe
some radium, and I carve
out a little thing here,
and maybe I put some plates
to kind of protect scatter,
I can make a beam
of this stuff, OK?
So this would be like
maybe radium, let's say.
And then what he did is he
took this photographic plate
and he curved it, just so
he could really collect
as much as you could, right?
So you can really collect
at really high angles.
And he did the same thing.
He put charged plates
on either side,
and he found that you had
three different types of beams.
He had one that went like
this, one that went like this,
and one that went like this.
And we now know that this
is beta, this is gamma,
and that's alpha.
Let's put this right above.
This is so cool to watch.
So what Rutherford did
is kind of like this.
He had stuff and he
made a beam of it,
and then he put stuff around it.
But if you got a
beam of something
that might be
charged, you're not
going to smash it or burn it.
You're going to put
some plates around it,
or a magnetic field
or electric field.
And that's what he did.
And notice, alpha bends down,
towards the positive charge,
towards the negative charge.
So alpha must be
positively charged.
I said, OK, that sounds cool.
Maybe I can use this.
Maybe I can use this on
this, on this question
of how these things are
spatially distributed.
So then he said, OK,
let's just screen out
those alpha particles.
And let's just take these alpha
particles and let's shoot them.
So now comes the
famous experiment,
so you had stuff in here,
radium making a beam.
And you collect it and you
make it just alpha particles.
OK?
So now he's just got all alpha
particles, and what he did
is he also had a
photographic plate,
or this could also be
a phosphorus screen,
and you can watch where--
You know, if it's a photographic
plate, you record events,
and you can see it
like a picture, a film.
And if it's a screen,
then you watch it.
Either one was used.
But what he did is he put a very
thin strip of gold in there.
0.7 microns of gold, so that's
a 0.7 thickness is 0.7 microns.
Really, really thin, like
a tissue paper of gold.
And he shot these
alpha particles at it.
Now, why is this important?
Because-- gesundheit.
Because if this model
of the atom was correct,
then, you know, he'd isolated
these positive particles
that he's shooting
at these atoms.
If that model of
the atom is correct,
then this is kind of like
distributed all over.
Right?
And so it's kind of neutral
almost anywhere you look.
It's kind of neutral.
And so you would expect that a
positive charge-- you'd maybe
feel a little bit,
but it kind of
feels mostly neutral because
it's evenly distributed.
So it just kind of come out,
but that's not what he saw.
That's not what he saw.
What he saw is that
sometimes that would happen.
You'd get a little
bit of deflection.
And other times,
you'd get a signal
out here, or there, or even
right back at the radium.
How is that possible?
This did not work.
That model of the
atom did not work.
And Rutherford himself said,
it was almost as incredible
as if you fired a 15-inch shell
at a piece of tissue paper
and it came back and hit
you, because they just
didn't expect that a
positive particle could
bounce backward off of an
even distribution of charge.
And so this is a picture
from your textbook, Avril,
that I know you are actively
reading on a daily basis.
So there's the alpha particles.
That's what I drew,
that they would expect--
or that what I mentioned.
They would expect it to
just kind of pass through.
This is what was found,
where they kind of come back
at very sharp angles.
That's what he actually
observed, right?
And it led to the
Rutherford atom.
And the Rutherford
atom was that, look,
the only way that
this can happen,
that you get these events, where
a positive charge comes back
like that, is if there's a
very, very strong concentration
of the positive charge
in one small place.
And so he said--
let me see if I can
read my date correctly--
1912.
And so Rutherford, he said
that the positive charge
has to be in the middle,
and then the electrons
must be far away.
And that is also sometimes, it
was called the planetary model.
And in fact, there
was another scientist
from Japan, Nangaioka, who, five
years earlier, had predicted--
although he sort of predicted
this, because he loved Saturn.
[LAUGHTER]
He really did.
So he said, you know,
it seems that maybe we
have a Saturn situation.
So he called it the
Saturnian model.
But I want to mention it because
it was part of the way there.
Right?
But in this planetary
model, which
came from Rutherford's
experiments,
you had a very different
picture now of the atom.
You had a very
different picture.
You had all the
positive charge really
concentrated in the middle.
Now, the thing is
also that the atom,
what they were
starting to understand
is that the atom isn't just--
like, there isn't just
all this space here.
Right?
They knew the electrons weren't
distributed evenly in here.
They knew they were
sort of far away.
There is a lot of space.
There's a lot of space,
that the radius of the atom
is 100,000 times bigger than
the radius of the nucleus.
Right?
So just to put that
in perspective,
so here's a picture.
There would be the
nucleus, the head of a pin.
And this would be
the atom, a stadium.
OK?
If you took all this stuff,
all the stuff in a human body--
that means the
protons, all the stuff
in the nuclei, the neutrons--
ooh, I'm getting there!
And the electrons, and
you take 7 billion people,
and you put that
all into one volume,
it is the volume
of a sugar cube.
So you know, so things are
pretty empty out there.
Things are pretty
empty out there.
How empty are they?
But this is where you
find true meaning.
This is deep!
How empty is stuff?
Look, if I weigh the universe,
you know, the universe itself,
we're going from the atom and
the electron, all the way up
to the universe.
The universe weighs
something like, oh, 10
to 60-ish kilograms.
That's over roughly
$30 billion lightyears.
OK, now, if we just do the math,
so you weighed the universe.
You know how big it is, roughly.
Plus of give or minus--
plus or minus.
Then that means that 10 to the
minus 20% of the whole universe
is stuff.
And the rest is empty.
That's deep, because we find
meaning in all of it, don't we?
That's deep.
Think about that.
That's not just the
universe, but the atom.
It's the same.
You know, so much of
everything is nothing.
OK, planetaria, but
there was a problem
with the planetary model.
There was a big problem
with the planetary model,
because classical ENM
told us that if, you know,
if a charge is accelerating, if
a charge is accelerating, which
it is, because it's ughhh!
We think it's going around.
We think they're
going around here.
They are not!
Friday, we'll know
more about that.
But we thought they were.
But if it's accelerating,
you know, to keep the circle,
then it's got to be
radiating energy.
That's what classical
ENM tells us.
An accelerating
charge loses energy.
So if you go with that,
then the electron--
let's see, the stability
analysis that we get out
of something like that--
hang on-- is that the
atom would be stable,
four-ish 10 to the minus 11
seconds, five times, roughly.
That's not giving
us a lot of time.
All right?
And so we were getting so far.
We had this great model, but it
didn't go with classical ENM.
So atom's stable for that
with classical ENM, oh!
Because you know what's coming.
We're going quantum.
Not now, I'm just
preparing you for later--
Did I hear an oh?
Thank you.
Friday.
OK, so Bohr comes along,
and on Wednesday, we're
really going to go into Bohr.
And we're going to
talk about how Bohr's
model, how Bohr's
model of the atom
allowed us to understand how
light and matter interacts.
That's a big deal, right?
But we'll go into
that on Wednesday.
For now, I just want
to tell you what
he did, which is he thought
about this problem a lot.
He's like, this can't be.
We need some way out of this.
And he wrote this paper,
where he said the following.
He said, let's go over here.
He said, OK, "In
order to explain
the results of experiments on
scattering of alpha rays"--
we just did that,
scattering of alpha rays--
"by matter, Professor
Rutherford has given a theory
of the structure of atoms."
And then Bohr goes on.
And he says, "Great
interest is to be
attributed to this atom model."
Now, that is a serious diss.
Great interest?
If somebody calls your
model of great interest,
you know you are in trouble.
He might as well
have said back then,
you know, this model
is of great interest
because it's totally wrong!
[LAUGHTER]
And if you want to know
what's up, come over to me
and I'll tell you.
And that's what Bohr
helped with in his work.
And what he did is he
wrote down some postulates.
He said, look, the
Rutherford atom is correct,
but the problem here is
classical ENM theory.
Right?
You cannot apply classical
ENM theory to the orbiting
electron.
You can't, because
that's what happened.
So something's wrong
with literally nothing
less than classical physics.
Right?
He said, Newtonian mechanics
still works, right?
Newtonian mechanics
works, but not ENM.
So he said, we can
go classical on how
things are moving around.
F equals MA stuff, but not ENM.
He also postulated
that the energy
of these electrons, the energy
that these electrons sit at
or have--
we'll get into this a lot--
he hypothesized that
that's quantized.
Quantized.
We're saying that word.
It's a beautiful moment.
Quantized.
Quantized means
that it could only
have certain values,
certain values, which
means that if this electron
were to be in one value
and then change into another,
that the transitions are
quantized.
The transitions of an
electron from one energy
level of the atom to another
can only have certain values.
And that is what we get
from the Bohr model.
And boy, did it explain things!
That's going to be the subject
of Wednesday, as I mentioned.
Right?
But this gets us
to the Bohr model.
And here's Bohr.
We're now-- oh, I
got to draw this.
We got all the positive
charge in the middle,
and then these electrons
can only have certain radii,
certain energies.
They cannot continuously
roam around.
They can't.
They're quantized.
That's the Bohr model.
And this is closed in 1912.
This is closing in on the
last and final model, which
we'll get to this week, which
is where quantum mechanics comes
in.
OK, now, we got one more
thing to talk about.
So this is where we're going.
We're building up the full
understanding of the atom.
But there's one more thing
that I've got to come back to,
and that is that,
look, we just said
there are these positive
charges in there
and these negative
charges out there.
But it turns out that atoms
can have different masses
and stay neutral.
All right?
So we're now in a position
to talk about this thing
that we've been calling
the nucleus and the fact
that it's not just protons.
We're in a position
to talk about that.
And so, you know,
Rutherford gave us
this idea of the proton,
the particle, the proton.
And it wasn't until
12 years later
that Chadwick found the neutron.
What the neutron does is
it adds mass to the atom.
See, the mass didn't work.
So again, you know, if you know
what the mass of the proton is,
then you can add it up, and you
get the mass of the electron,
although it's like
1,000th as much.
But it doesn't work.
There's something else in
there that's adding mass.
But it's not adding charge,
because these things
are electrically neutral.
So those other particles
are called neutrons,
and what it does is it gives us
ranges of masses for the atoms.
Right?
It gives us ranges.
So because, you
know, hydrogen now.
If you think about it,
99.99% of all hydrogen
is just that thing on the
left, a proton and an electron.
But sometimes, it has a neutron.
So it weighs more.
It's still got neutral charge.
It's called deuterium.
And then you've got
tritium, which is unstable.
You can make it.
And these are called isotopes,
as many of you, I'm sure,
already know.
These are called isotopes, and
so the isotopes of an atom,
the isotopes of an atom
with the same atomic number,
different number of neutrons,
different number of neutrons.
So atoms have these
three things in them.
They've got the neutrons, the
protons, and the electrons.
We've been talking today about
the protons and the electrons,
but they got to have these
other things in them,
or the mass doesn't work.
And so if you look at
something like carbon,
you see the same thing.
And now I want to get
into how these things are
written, right?
Because here's carbon, and
there are those electrons.
They're now put out there.
OK, we didn't draw
circles, so maybe this
is around Rutherford's time
when Avril made this picture.
And there is the pluses, and
there's other things in there.
Right?
And those are the neutrons.
And so what we do is we have
a nomenclature for this,
which is the standard.
And that is that if we
write an element like this,
this would be the element.
And we put something here
and something here, this
is the mass number.
OK?
So that's how many
protons plus neutrons.
Neu-- ah!
Neutrons.
And this is called
the atomic number.
Now, the atomic number,
I've been referencing
this thing, this atomic number.
I've said, Mendeleev
and many others,
they put things in
order of atomic number,
maybe mass sometimes.
Mendeleev did the thing
where he did those things
and properties, right?
And the atomic number was
just a number, until later.
And once we discover
another type of ray,
x-rays, then this has real
physical meaning, right?
But right now, it's
still just a number.
It's a number of the element
in the periodic table.
Right?
But that mass number tells
me how many neutrons I have
and what the isotope is.
So now I go back.
I can go back, and I
can look at carbon.
Oh, by the way, carbon--
I wanted to write this
down before I say that.
Carbon, when you look it up in
the table, you have 12.011 AMU,
or grams per mole.
That's what's in the table.
But now you know why,
because it's just an average.
And in fact, the IUPAC,
which is a rocking body
of the International Union of
Pure and Applied Chemistry,
I'm sure you've seen
them on the feeds.
They hold meetings and in
Vienna on a nonstop night
of intense meeting and partying.
And they said,
hey, maybe in 2011,
maybe we should actually do
this with the periodic table,
just to show that
actually there really is
a range of-- if I take
carbon out of the ground here
or carbon out of
the ground there,
maybe they have
different AMUs, right?
These are averages,
and there are ranges.
So they're actually talking
about different ways
of even putting this into
periodic tables, right?
But this is it.
And this gets us back.
Oh, there's boron and
nitrogen ranges, right?
But what we do now, at least, is
we just look at the one number,
because that's sort
of averaged over,
you know, basically anywhere
you can dig this stuff up.
And the stable isotopes.
Stable isotopes.
And it gets me to
my last slide, which
just comes back to the
beginning, as I promised.
Right?
Because now I can say not only
how many gallium atoms are
in this strip, but
I can tell you,
gallium has two stable isotopes.
By the way, it's got a
bunch of unstable ones,
but it's got two stable ones,
gallium 69 and gallium 71.
And I can now ask you,
how many gallium 69 atoms
are in this strip?
How?
Because I can again look
up in the periodic table
and find that in
a gallium strip,
I know how many atoms I have.
But if I say, well, 69
times x plus 71 times 1
minus x, that's going
to equal 69.723 AMU.
That's what's in
the periodic table.
But I now know
that that's simply
an average over all the--
right?
So this would be the
fraction of 69 GA, right?
Because that's how simple these
isotope problems are, right?
It's simply averaging over the
potentially stable isotopes.
And I leave you with
one more great mystery.
As you are pondering
this, think about this.
There are two elements, ah!
There are two elements for which
there are no stable isotopes.
Technetium and promethium.
Nothing!
Technetium, we use all the time.
80% of all MRIs use technetium,
but it's not stable.
We got to make it, right?
That's pretty deep too.
How did that happen?
Why did that happen?
For the answer, you'll
have to stay tuned.
Have a good night, and
see you guys on Wednesday.